What do you plan on doing this Mtma therapy on a regular basis?
And what,
what sort of an impact do you think?
I mean,
when you go over the results of the first therapy where you are almost
immediately alleviates you have a lot of your feelings,
but you still are thinking about planning your next adventure and your,
your next project.
Um,
I'm probably going to do a full session.
The therapist recommended a full session,
which isn't what they normally do.
But that said,
I mean,
I thought,
I thought being able to cry,
it would be a major breakthrough.
And as part of this therapy,
um,
and actually do you normally can't cry at all?
I haven't cried since I was 13 years old or something.
14.
Well that's different because that predates your war correspondents.
Yeah.
I mean,
English culture,
it's,
you know,
my grandparents fought in the war were tough as nails.
It's,
you know,
there is this pressure to be,
to be tough.
Uh,
and the first normal therapy session,
I told her what I thought was quite an everyday story about an experience in war
to the therapist.
And he cried.
Oh,
Jesus.
And then the first MGMA session,
the therapist cried.
I didn't have two or three times in the camera,
man cried and I still,
I still couldn't get there.
And then the third session I nearly did and I liked my jaw was trembling and I
kinda thought,
oh,
there's,
there's going to be this,
what would have felt like a breakthrough and still hasn't happened.
What w what were they crying about?
Uh,
I can't even remember what stories you just had to share has been Obama.
Like the stories,
I just tell him that,
you know,
well,
I mean,
I'm joking kind of joke.
It's this very happy you're talking about it.
This is one of the,
you know,
one of the lesser symptoms of doing this as you turn up to a party or a dinner
or something,
you know,
with people that are enjoying this out,
that sales,
the smiling,
it was like,
oh,
this is Ben.
Ben just come back from,
from Yemen.
I would say like in Yemen,
Ben,
you really,
really want to know.
Yeah,
tell us.
And then 10 minutes later there's this dark cloud of evening and everyone says,
oh Jesus.
So you just feel like you're,
you know,
you're just killing,
killing the,
they're cutting and their steak and you're talking to,
yeah,
your leg amputated.
And I've got bad habit of doing that,
but I can't even remember what the is where that,
that,
that had that effect.
What does it like when you go to dinner with fellow war journalists?
Um,
what are you guys talking about?
I know there's a few that are already good friends and we can talk about all
that stuff.
There's a lot of that.
I'm not,
I'm not that close to,
and I don't like the,
you know,
the,
the mutual,
you know,
um,
backpacking that goes on with it.
And it was,
I what it is,
I kind of think,
you know,
if you're doing this for a living,
like you,
you,
you shouldn't be sharing stories with other people who cover that country.
Other other people from,
you know,
from your background,
from your country,
you should be talking to the people from that country and a lot of journalists,
I mean,
it's possible in Afghanistan,
in Syria,
in Iraq,
to have a pretty good life.
You stay in the five star hotel,
you eat well,
drink wine every night,
and you know,
you get information from each other.
Right.
And I think that defeats the point of,
of foreign reporting.
Oh,
I see.
So consciously or unconsciously,
I,
I'm not,
you know,
I don't,
I don't spend a lot of time with,
with other watch unless there were,
there were those who were deeply admire who I see every now and again,
like Sebastian younger.
Um,
but I'm not,
I don't,
I don't hang out with them day in,
day out.
So there's levels to the involvement.
Yeah.
To,
whether,
how deeply you're immersed and it's,
it's,
it's completely upside down in the state because the TV,
new Gen TV news journalists aren't deeply involved and just want to get that
quick shot of them looking like that somewhere Middle East,
he closest to the front line with the flak jacket on the perfectly ironed shirt
and they're not,
they're not sweating or even worse,
the Brian Williams type situation.
Yeah,
yeah.
Or on the roof of the five star hotel.
Sometimes you might see people report about what's happening with Isis and
they're in Beirut.
Right.
And I think they're relying on the fact that a lot of people don't understand
that's a different country.
Um,
but you know,
those guys,
some of those guys are paid millions and treated very,
very well.
The photographers and print journalists who are immersed and aren't spending
weeks there as sometimes struggling to make a living and aren't well known and
aren't well supported.
What is it about the talking head in front of the camera that we want so badly?
I mean,
I think it's,
it's a way for the news networks to,
to,
you know,
claim credibility and then when you see them get deployed,
they're not focused on getting material from the war in these countries.
They're focused on the,
on the two way.
Right now it's essentially a guy from wherever.
Right.
That's more important than actually spending days collecting footage of what's
actually going on.
It seems like you see that rarely if ever these days it's more and more rare.
And it seemed to me that during like Desert Storm,
um,
in the 90s,
there was always someone that was over there and it seemed like there was real
threat and it was really going on.
But now everything seems to be done from the desk and you don't really see a lot
of,
I mean,
am I right about that?
Yeah.
I mean,
I think in most of a lot of the major news networks said to their crews,
you're not allowed to spend the night in Mosul.
You know,
you can go there and film a street interviews,
some refugees who just escaped isis territory,
but you can't spend days on end there.
Whereas the freelance photographers and some of the writers,
they were spending days on end there and getting,
getting the real stuff.
Is it because the on camera people will be targeted?
Um,
I just think the risk is too high,
full stop for the entire crew.
And certainly if you know,
when a story is really big and you send one of the very well known of
correspondence there,
then yeah,
they can't be running around,
um,
you know,
filming house to house fighting.
So when you're over there and you see these guys show up and you know that
they're just going to be hanging out with the hotel and what is that feeling
like?
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
I'm pretty disdainful of those guys.
You have to,
yeah.
Yeah.
You see these films like,
um,
whiskey,
tango,
Foxtrot about Afghanistan and I just,
yeah,
I just don't recognize that,
that world that,
you know,
partying every night at whatever bar or restaurant.
I just,
I just think if you're there and you're obviously in the wrong place,
right,
right.
And it's not,
it's not an adventure,
you know,
it's not a fun trip for you of,
of wild times.
And you know,
it shouldn't be that.
It should be,
um,
I mean from,
it feels like an endurance test every time you go.
It should be hard and you should be spending time with the people you're
covering.
And you know,
sometimes you can,
you can think you've finished with someone and just go for dinner or tea.
And just by having normal human conversations,
you find out so much other stuff that you didn't go there to report on.
You know,
that's,
that's what you have to be doing.
And that takes weeks,
weeks of getting closer to them and gain their trust.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And just,
just,
you know,
spending enough time there where you,
you then end up being in the right place at the right time to show something
really happening.
I mean in Mosul,
we filmed a,
the Iraqi army attacking a house where Isis was shooting from the house and
there were three or four families in the house.
Um,
so the Iraqi army shot at Isis or the isis guys went down and encourage the
families to run towards us.
And just seeing that moment of civilians fleeing and escaping isis for the first
time after three years.
And when they turned the corner and tore us,
they knew that made it,
and they just collapsed to the ground.
They were kissing the ground.
They were hugging each other.
Now those are the moments you,
you,
you're,
you're trying to capture.
Just,
I mean,
I've never seen relief like it.